all right I am on the free code camp
homepage and I have opened up the
developer tools I did it this time by
going to view developer and developer
tools came right up and I went to the
network tab so here's some stuff is
already loaded based on when I opened
when I opened the developer tools and
when i refresh the page i refresh again
you'll notice a whole lot of information
but we're most interested in is this
network tab here there are all of these
different color-coded things each one of
them represents a different item on the
page so here on the lower side it
actually lists them out like this image
which we right-click or if we double
click and pardon me it comes up and
misses the gifts the googling gifts that
it shows so here it shows the timing of
everything the content download took the
longest it was almost 67 milliseconds
basically this is useful it's color
coded so once you're comfortable that
the colors mean you can really at a
quick glance look through and say okay
well this item took a really long time
what is that and this gift took a lot
longer to load than anything else so if
your page or your app was taking a
really long time to load or to get a
request something was taking a long time
the network tab could kind of help you
figure out exactly what it was if it was
the request getting sent out if it was
waiting like this one was the request
sent out really fast
it was just waiting the content download
was quick too so it helps you figure out
exactly where the problem is and
pinpoint it so you can fix it really
quickly just like all my other videos
I'm going to tell you go look at the
documentation it is awesome it is super
helpful and very easy to read and in
depth at the same time but what I want
you to take away from this video is the
network tab is where you can look at how
long each part of a request is taking
for every single aspect in your web page